[Music]
john is in
texas hi john welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hey dr d and dave how are you guys doing
great how can we help
um well i'll try to keep it brief um 31
years old
baby step four um they've been listening
to you
since 2016. um
going through this journey i've um you
know paid off all my dad in
18 months and full emergency fund and
everything like that
but i just feel like
i have something missing in my life
and it's something that i think might be
the spirituality side of um
everything that you teach um i have
i was raised by non-practicing
muslims and uh and so i never really had
any kind of religion or any kind of
spirituality in my life
and it's something that's kind of
getting bigger and bigger inside of me
and it you know i don't know if it's
that for sure but
i know that i definitely have something
missing in my life
so kind of just wanted to call in and
ask
uncle dave and uncle well i was pretty
much the same way when i was a little
bit younger than you about 24.
and i read a quote years later that kind
of explained it
um pascal said in
um in every man there is a god-shaped
hole
and sometimes we try to throw things in
that hole
people do it with drugs and they get
become drug addicts people do it with
material things and they become
materialistic people do it with
pornography and they become addicted to
that and so on right people try
everything in the world to fill
the hole that is that really only has
one
thing that fits in it and properly
and that is the spiritual walk it is god
and that made sense to me when
i heard it and i was sitting in a seat
similar to the one you're sitting in
right now
um you see what i'm saying yes sir
so it's natural in other words to kind
of have this
everything's going along it seems like
i'm doing well but there still feels
like this
something's missing that's a fairly
natural thing it's the way
that's the way we're designed and that's
what i discovered anyway i was
i was in my mid-20s early 20s when
when i discovered that uh you're a touch
older but
uh than i was at that time so and the
same situation i didn't grow up in a
muslim non-practicing muslim home but we
weren't church people so to speak
and so um good people nothing wrong with
the morals or anything like that that's
not the point
but uh the point was this whole
discussion wasn't something that ever
came up
so um i i did what you're doing and i
kind of went on a quest
and i started trying to learn about it
and i tried to find people
that that uh weren't kooky that actually
made sense
when they were talking about spiritual
things and some of them are kookier than
crud i'll just tell you
but uh uh but i found you know some
people that were fairly level-headed and
would walk me through it and i
became introduced to the bible and i
started reading that and
i started going to a non-kooky church
there are seven of those across the
country
and uh uh warning you ahead of time i
mean because i
i have discovered in 40 or 40 years of
doing this stuff that
there's nothing kookier than a kooky
christian so um
but uh but yeah you know so
i i would tell you to try to poke around
do you have any good friends that you
feel like in your
circle that are uh that could maybe give
you recommendations maybe they're not
up to coaching you on this subject but
they could say hey i'll hook you up with
this guy this pastor over here i know is
a really good guy and he can answer some
questions for you
you know anybody like that
i do i just feel like
at the same time i'm kind of resisting
it it's almost like i i feel like i'm
missing it in my life but i'm also
afraid because i'm afraid if i like for
example turn
to um christianity which is actually the
most i
know about any religion is because
listening through you
that i would maybe be judged by
you know like family well you would be
you know you would be
i don't think there's any question about
that and that's not even a
i mean it's accelerated i mean it's it's
it's more
prominent because of your your family's
heritage
but as dave mentioned i don't think that
i don't think that means christians
but christians feel that too when they i
mean if uh
if you go from a catholic church to a
baptist church or i'm going to go to a
different baptist church on the street
that's just whenever you decide to
really go on a journey to find out who
you are
and why you're disconnected um people
around you don't understand that there's
always going to be someone that goes
well that's not the way that's not the
way you know and well i'm
this is my journey this is my walk and
so
um i mean some of my old beer drinking
buddies that i used to raise hell with
didn't understand you know uh different
religion right
but but they didn't understand they're
like what what happened to you man
well you're no fun anymore man i'm like
yeah i'm more fun but in a different way
that's right so i got my crap together
finally
so um but your fear john as you're
standing over the prep
precipice when you're looking over the
edge of a cliff and you know
if i take this step there's a chance
that everything that i know is different
it's normal to be scared of that yeah um
that's that's what bravery is bravery is
not going and doing
like going to battle when you know the
outcome it's knowing that i'm scared i'm
gonna go do it anyway you know
i think i'd you know once you sit down
and maybe write out four or five things
that you need the answer to
that doesn't mean you necessarily uh
so you know start wearing around a shirt
that says i'm a baptist or something you
just are you're just
starting to get some answers and uh one
of them might be
you know how to handle uh you know
some negative input from from people in
your past
um and i think that's pretty standard
anytime anyone makes any kind of shift
um i mean i've known people that just
changed
denominations and because their whole
social structure was tied up in their
denomination and everything else
and and people are like they think
they're the only ones going to heaven is
that particular
denomination and then you know friends
don't talk to they rule you out you know
and so i've known that to happen and so
you know you've got a they would have to
ask the same question as my point
and so uh but i i don't think there's
any requirement that
because you asked someone five or six
questions over coffee three times
that all of a sudden you you got sucked
into something you know i don't think
there's a requirement of that
if you'll gather more information you'll
start to see things
more clearly and more than then we can
give you on run radio call truthfully
and john can i burst your bubble before
we hang up
yes sir avoiding this is not going to
make it go away
that hole doesn't go away by by running
from it
and i've been avoiding it i know i know
you have i can hear it
i'm just telling you that feeling you
feel that emptiness that disconnect
you're afraid if you step over into the
tractor beam it's going to suck you in
you know and like you're going to lose
control or something and you never
our faith anyway you never lose your
choice
you've always got a choice you get to
decide there's no
nothing you know no uh mind
sucking amoeba that takes your brain out
and then you're not allowed to make
choices anymore you still will make the
choice
all the way along the rest of your life
no matter what that doesn't stop
at any point so you don't have to be
afraid about this getting out of control
so to speak if it gets out of control
it's because you
chose to take steps and you no one
made you do anything along that way so
if i were you i'd talk to one of your
buddies that's got a real good pastor
what city in texas
are you in dallas okay
great very cool there's your church on
every 11th
foot right you know where that is
yeah there's tons of tons of great
places around there and we've got lots
of friends there that we could hook you
up to
if you need to too but i would just find
somebody and continue the journey
continue
asking questions uh because john's right
this is
this has been awakened inside of you and
until you get the questions answered
it's going to
it's going to scratch and claw at your
heart and that's a good thing
go be brave yeah i'm proud of you if you
want to talk some more call me back
anytime